die idylle trügt hier zumindest für mich
denn mir wird gleich etwas tatsächlich
grauenhaftes passieren
grauenhaft ist es jedenfalls für die
600.000 von epilepsie betroffenen
menschen die in deutschland ich werde
einen solchen anfall erleben und zwar
mit hilfe dieser verbringe hier am rhein
da sitzt die pharmafirma ocb und sie
forscht in sachen epilepsie
mein name ist christoph krachten
herzlich willkommen im rahmen der
kampagne forschung ist die beste medizin
vorfahr das ist der verband der
forschenden pharma-unternehmen bin ich
hier am rhein bz
ja da sitze ich nun und werde jetzt
einen absoluten horror leben über eine
brille erlebe ich subjektiv also in der
haut einer epileptischen einen
epileptischen anfall das video selbst
können wir aus copyright gründen nicht
zeigen
entwickelt wurde es für das
pharmaunternehmen ocb wir werden jetzt
die brille aufsetzen darf ich dich hab
kurz an die sause ja mal ist er so
ausgeliefert
so haben wir jetzt wochenlang darauf
gewartet jetzt ist es soweit
das ist hier mehr bammel alstom
achterbahn fahren aber dann schauen wir
mal wie befinden uns gerade im
restaurant woher krachten die position
von jain eingenommen hat 76 patienten
und die situation ist jetzt folgende
sally möchte gerne die telefonnummer von
james bekommen kriegt aber wie kommt es
aber nicht hin
die telefonnummer im wiederzugeben und
vertauschte beziffern
in dem fall ist es so dass sie ihre
gedanken nicht artikulieren kann
obwohl ich ja den anfangen und mittelbar
über ein vr video erlebe steigt der puls
jetzt stehen wir kurz vor allem an fall
wo die wogen in die bewusstlosigkeit
verfällt beiden laufen zurzeit so viele
gedanken in ihrem kopf herum dass sie
auch da nicht ganz genau weiß was sie
tun will möchte gerne nach hilferufen
schafft es aber nicht
und gerät dann in die bewusstlosigkeit
im video war ich der situation
vollkommen ausgeliefert meine gedanken
konnte ich nicht in worte fassen und war
nicht in der lage mit den menschen in
meinem umfeld zu sprechen ich fühlte
mich absolut wehrlos und ausgeliefert
nachdem anfang werde ich von sarah
angesprochen selbst epileptiker in
[Musik]
entschuldigen sie bedecken sie sich
nicht sie hatten einen epileptischen
anfall
wie geht es ihm ja das ganze muss ich
sagen war also ich hatte das gefühl mich
selbst zu verlieren
also wann ist man wird so abgekoppelt
von seiner wenn man das weg also man ist
also bei meinem fall man kriegt das
baywa kriegt es mit
und warum sind sie jetzt hier
ich habe den anfang mit erlebnis- und
sie müssen sich keine sorgen machen ich
habe mich gar nicht vorgestellt ich bin
sache und ich hab selbst epilepsie okay
deswegen konnte ich ihn auch direkt
helfen und wusste was zu tun ist okay
was machen sonst menschen wenn sie so
was erleben
die meisten menschen sind hilflos weil
sie noch nie ein anfang miterlebt haben
und dadurch überfordert man bekommt also
man bekommt denn den weg dorthin mit
dass man langsam so die kontrolle über
sich verliert so habe ich selbst erlebt
ist das bei ihnen ähnlich und vom
eigentlichen anfall mann ist aber wächst
das ist richtig ich habe leider keine
auch das sind diese vor gefühle das
gefühl dass sich ein anfall andeutet es
gibt ganz verschiedene formen mancher
meinen sagen zum beispiel sein gefühl im
bauch andere etwas im arm und ich bin
leider einfach nur weg genau man ist
also ja also das also beim versuch es
mal ist es sich für mich war das ein
vollkommen neues gefühl weil das ist
auch so gemacht dass man sich wirklich
wie diese person fühlt und man merkt wie
man eben die gedanken und das was man
sagt komplett auseinander laufen und ja
man hat so das gefühl wenn ich kann das
ist wirklich echt nicht zu beschreiben
diesen sie das beschreiben
ich habe die gefühle die die frau im
video schon formen an fall hat die kenne
ich auch von der zeit nach dem anfall
ich weiß nicht wie viel zeit vergangen
ist werde oft überhäuft mit fragen und
in meinem kopf kann ich diese fragen
auch beantworten aber ich kann gar nicht
so schnell reagieren
während des anfalls und die artikulation
fällt mir zum beispiel schwer
für mich fühlt sich so ein epileptischer
anfall ein bisschen an wie ein
systemabsturz der sich dem opa am
computer
er stürzt ab und muss langsam heraus
fahren und diese hilflosigkeit und der
kontrollverlust sind eigentlich auch die
schlimmsten gefühle die man dann nach
einem anfall hat oder auch schon wenn
man eine aura hat davor dass man das
gefühl hat man möchte gerne handeln man
möchte auch sich gerne selbst helfen
möchte ich einen anderen leuten
mitteilen was man braucht oder was sie
tun sollten aber man ist nicht in der
lage weil man keine kontrolle mehr über
den eigenen körper hat man ist ja quasi
zwei persönlichkeiten mann ist derjenige
der das alles mitbekommt der genau weiß
was da passiert und zweites mal
derjenige der also total eingeschränkt
nur in anführungszeichen funktioniert
genau ich versuche das noch mal zu
erklären mit dem fernsehen mit der
stimme aus dem off die bei mir im kopf
auch über gelagert ist es gibt die
stimme im kopf die sagt ich heiße sarah
ich habe epilepsie es ist diagnostiziert
ich möchte gerne liegen und ruhe haben
vielleicht etwas trinken und es gibt die
sarah die leider überhaupt nicht in der
lage ist darauf zu reagieren
wie fühlen sie sich in so einem moment
hilflos und halt dass ich die kontrolle
über meinen körper also dass da eine
jemand anderes die kontrolle hat die
seinem ein marionettenspieler der
eigentlich auch welches bewegt das weiß
ich nicht
wovor haben sie angst ich versuche mich
von meiner angst nicht leiten zu lassen
deswegen ist es schwer zu sagen ich habe
aber immer angst dass das ich einen
anfall in einer situation habe oder in
einem moment wo es besonders unpassend
ist zb jetzt also wirklich ein
erschreckendes erlebnis muss ich sagen
also für mich also es hat sich so
angefühlt und ich habe jetzt aber ihnen
auch den eurovision fremdes monster was
besitz von einem
er greift genau ich nenne es einen
panther der dunkel und gefährlich ist
der hinter jeder ecke lauern könnte und
mich aus dem nichts überfallen ohne
vorwarnung und das schleichen im moment
um uns herum
inzwischen kann epilepsie schon sehr gut
behandelt werden allerdings fehlt das
verständnis über den umgang mit
patientinnen und patienten
sarah hat mich gerade sehr sanft und
verständnisvoller angesprochen meistens
wird aber nach einem solchen anfall auf
die betroffenen eingeredet und sie
können gar nicht darauf reagieren das
unternehmen zb setzt dieses vr video ein
um bei ärzten und in der öffentlichkeit
dafür ein besseres bewusstsein für
epileptische anfälle zu schaffen und
selbst ärzte sind überrascht darüber wie
ein solcher anfall abläuft ein bisschen
frische luft was ist denn damit mir
passieren das war ja ein absolutes
erlebnis
ja es könnte sehr viel eicher
nachvollziehen wie sich ein patient
anfühlt oder fühlen muss wenn vor allen
dingen wenn sie sowas mehrmals am tag
erleben müssen das ist natürlich so
einfach wie patienten und den soll es
auch für die familien woher kommt das
das ist das scheiden sich die geister
also bei 50 prozent der patienten weiß
man welche ursachen es gibt die 51% ob
man im dunkeln
eine störung im gehirn wo er die
stoffwechselprozesse nicht ganz genau
funktionieren und dann letztendlich zu
einer veränderung der gehirnstruktur
kommt dasselbe gilt auch für eine
entzündliche ursache da entstehen
entzündungen im gehirn die dann auch zum
fertigen anfall führen können
also mal wieder forschung ist die beste
medizin zeigt sich auch hier
ich würde mal sagen vielen dank für die
tollen informationen und den tiefen
einblick vor allen dingen für mich das
war echt ein erlebnis was ich so schnell
nicht vergessen werde werden wir bald
alle cyborg sedlmeier link anklicken
anschauen und natürlich nicht um
science-fiction abonnieren falls es noch
nicht getan haben sollte bis dann bleibt
dran